each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good morning and thanks for coming to
the talk so today it's a great pleasure
to have professor Randall burns from
john hopkins university professor burns
is associated professor at john hopkins
university in a computer science
department and he is a founding member
of john hopkins institute for intense
data-intensive science and engineering
and then professor burn got his BS from
Stanford University and then ms and a
PhD from UC Santa Cruz and then
professor Verne has very good industry
experience because he worked as a
research staff at IBM at Mountain
Research Center so without further ado
let's hear professor British talk thank
you alright so I um I'm going to talk
about high-throughput data-intensive
computing and and basically give you an
overview of some work that we did in
context of scientific computing that
Yahoo did in the context of cloud
computing and workflows and then the
merger of the two which is where we are
right now um and so this is sort of the
the last five years after MapReduce
really took off that became a big
interest in in figuring out how to do
resource sharing among multiple
MapReduce jobs that's the topic of the
talk so um this is a Prezi if you
haven't seen a Prezi before it's
essentially just as bad as PowerPoint
but has the additional benefit of making
you seasick um but it entertains me a
little bit and so that it's a it's a
zooming whiteboard model and so if you
feel nauseated feel free to leave the
room um okay so so this work started in
2008-2009 where we were looking at
scientific databases and trying to
figure out how to take multiple queries
and allow them to share io at the same
time in in 2008 crystal Santana's Pig
group at Yahoo whee
working on merging MapReduce jobs um our
work is subsequently gone on to look at
shared jobs in scientific databases
where jobs here is a is a simple form of
a workflow it's essentially an iterated
workflow rather than a branching
workflow that's important for for our
users a finer-grained optimization
called shared streaming i/o where we
actually um take reorder data access
dreams sorry data access patterns into
sequential streams flow coherency and
improve throughput and then the latest
work is is the the team that worked on
the scientific computing stuff the
student went to yahoo and we had a big
wedding and had been working in that in
a cloud again in nova which is Yahoo's
workflow engine in pig which is a semi
declarative programming language on top
of MapReduce and in Hadoop so workflows
means joins I think joins us a really
important part of making this type of
shared scheduling work enjoins are a
little more difficult so I think that
the big takeaway so if you wanted to
leave the room right this second the
thing that you would need to know is
that that sharing io is not enough so if
you look at multiple workloads and they
have common data requirements just
taking the the two workloads and making
them share the i/o is not is not
minimizing resource consumption and
maximizing throughput there's a lot more
opportunity to share network access to
share memory access all the way through
the memory hierarchy even in co execute
programs and this can be realized by
taking battery into programs and
coalesce them into one program right
there are tons of security implement
implications and other things that go
along with this but but we're looking
from a from a resource usage throughput
standpoint we're going to take workflows
at the end of this and put them together
and run them as one program so that that
as you access data through the whole
memory hierarchy is being accessed once
and delivered to programs ok so the
MapReduce perspective on this problem is
that map produces this gain engine at
least in the map phase often in many
subsequent phases sharing scandal
you to reduce usage among multiple jobs
and the networking and memory cost as
well I already hit that um and so the
the goal here is going to be to co
schedule multiple MapReduce jobs so they
use the same partitioning functions that
they use the same shuffle functions and
can share I can share reducers and based
on code rewriting um and that's where
the the cloud work came from the
scientific database work is that that
we've got these batch queries and when
you get multiple batch queries against
the data intensive service that we see a
throughput collapse um any one user can
sort of use all the i/o resources
available in the cluster so the queries
have again common data requirements and
use common indexes and so we wanted to
build a multi query optimizer for sharda
databases these actually turn out to be
the exact same task Just In in MapReduce
and databases and so ultimately the same
algorithms in the same IO techniques
work it's a little bit easier to
coalesce database queries and it is
general MapReduce jobs but the the end
goal is the same okay so as a start I'm
going to review this this first result
in I oh sherry from MapReduce that's
from the the pig team Yahoo um and so so
they observe that many map produced jobs
are essentially just very lightweight
maps that then compute simple aggregates
or do almost nothing in the reducer and
at this point MapReduce becomes simply
scan engine and the examples that they
have our OLAP log processing web
crawling and so most of this work is in
these scans and these scans can be
shared relatively easily so this is the
low-hanging fruit um and then their
approach was to take jobs and put them
into job families in which a job family
is a set of different tasks that access
the same file or scan the same files and
then to to execute these job families in
batches um according to some different
principles the the highest throughput
way to do it to minimize maximum late
see yep is uh is to do fifo ordering on
job families but that's their actually
end up targeting average latency and
they come up with this policy that that
is a little wacky um in and so this is
their their quote from their paper which
is scheduled policies revolve around the
notion that all else being equal it's
good to schedule non terrible scans
ahead of ones that can cheerio with
future jobs what this means is that
they're executing the jobs with the
least data sharing immediately deferring
not not jobs the files that are part of
a MapReduce job they're executing the
files with the least data sharing
immediately deferring the most popular
files to the end and the idea is that
that other MapReduce jobs will then want
will will merge onto that file and then
you can execute a bigger batch okay so
so I understand the intuition in the
argument at basis if you have an online
arrival rate and you allow work to
accumulate the arithmetic works out it's
sort of weird for me because I only know
two things in computer science and
that's that's hierarchy in the greedy
principle and this one is neither um and
and so little against my intuition but
for this online arrival rate model they
get a 50-percent performance throughput
increase and and that's mostly just from
sharing so comparing with with 50
ordering with and there's a bunch of
policies I only want you to take an
impression out of this graph and I'm not
going to be talking I'm going to show
you some graphs for the most part
they're gonna have things like oblivious
sjf that I don't remember what it is
much less want you to care um but so
fifty percent throughput increases nice
and this is on there um this is on
workload derived from their their
internal they call it the grid the
internal grid at Yahoo
so she drops there's a lot of data
overlapping job yeah so it's it's you
know they're scanning the same log files
there indexing the same web pages
movable schlongs
yeah well within the the duration of the
job right and so so this is all in this
batch computing model where jobs run
four minutes to potentially hours yeah
so that in and so they there's also
hidden things like how long does the job
sit in the queue before it's ready to
start executing how long is the set-up
time because if you're going to
accumulate work or you need to have it's
much like disk drive scheduling and you
need of lots of pending iOS to do
meaningful reordering you need to have
jobs queued up to to execute them
together very much and that reduce
Custer there's been a lot of data a
store in this cluster I so
people will go a man
and how come it is fine Bates and
commonalities
so the the answer is there a systematic
reuse of particular data sets so
incrementals on the crawl log processing
and what Yahoo found is that there's
there's this huge body of data but
there's also new data that was collected
or data that's temporal um in popular
data that gets reused and so it they're
saying that that on in total that
they're getting fifty percent throughput
increase this is actually be the lowest
number i'm going to show you um i don't
have great insight into their workload
in and the later benchmarking results
that i participated in that i'm going to
show you are from something called pig
mix which is their internal cloud
benchmark so when they deploy services
they have this they've attracted what
the yahoo work load looks like published
a cloud benchmark for that internally
and that's what we evaluate on so i
don't it's not the best answer your
question that's i can answer the
question for scientific data and we'll
see it okay so some some observations
about this first result so it's it's
it's job oriented and has job oriented
completion which means that that your
measure is when if you submit a job in
the jobs can scan one thousand files
your your measure is one that thousand
file is is scanned and completed and and
so it doesn't really account for
instantaneous throughput waiting time
doesn't accumulate against any
individual file right you don't care
whether you do a whole bunch of work at
the front and one piece at the end um
it's not clear that that's appropriate
it ignores caching oh and this is going
to be important because when we tackle
the similar problem in parallel we came
from a very different standpoint we use
greedy principles because that's one of
the two things like I know how to do and
because it'll it allows for some caching
opportunistically that the data that
then your buffer pool is getting reused
and so you've got your most popular data
pool data in the buffer pool and you're
getting opportunity
stick reuse and avoiding io actually um
that it ignores bursty workloads right
if you get a burst in and you're
deferring all your work for later um
it's I guess the thing is just this idea
that your system is always consumed in
that doing small I'm sorry doing
unpopular iOS as the saying is same as
doing popular iOS where if you had a
bursty system you want to be greedy and
get the maximum throughput of your
popular files immediately oh and there's
no guarantees on starvation okay so but
good throughput nice starting place I'm
now going to sag and because this is
where I get some skin in the game and we
get into some of the work that we did in
my lab um and so the rest of this talk
is structures followed I'm going to give
you a sort of brief overview of our
ideas which is a Institute for data
intensive engineering science at Johns
Hopkins um some of the data sets and
applications we work with and that'll
provide some motivation for well that's
then the specific data intensive
turbulence database cluster service that
we provide and then all of our
scheduling work um and this will be a
brief overview of bad scheduling bat
scheduling for jobs streaming scheduling
and then on into join scheduling all
right so the Institute for day intensive
engineering science we've been at it for
three years we've had the Institute
we've been collaborating for 12 years
I've been there nine and this all
started when when Jim Gray uh who used
to work at some company in redmond um
came and started clobbering without
delay on on the Sloan Digital Sky Survey
so this is essentially taking an optical
telescope mapping the sky putting in a
chartered database providing public
access to the community um it was the
first demonstration the impact that data
intensive science and and sort of
clustered databases can
have on science itself um and so so
notably that this Sloan Digital Sky
Survey is the most important telescope
in the world more important than Hubble
more important than swift um and it's
not because it's a great telescope I
mean don't get me wrong it's perfectly
fine telescope in the world of
telescopes this is I'd be happy to have
this one but what it is is everyone can
use it it's never cloudy it's a
community resource um it allows for
arbitrary reuse retrospective studies
and so just the the semantics of being
able to access this data to write
different queries to to do hypothesis
generation and refinement has made it
that this is the most used telescope and
we've been hosting that four dozen years
we've gone on to expand into lots more
data intensive science field so high
energy physics computational fluid
dynamics which is kind of my interest is
in or my day since I'm most involved
with our fluid dynamics brain connect
omics and imaging and astrophysics but
in total we're spending about almost
three petabytes now um which we think is
big now the the comment and i made this
to chang earlier is that i think of
large data computing and academia as
being on order of a hundred times bigger
than what you can do on your desktop and
a hundred times smaller than what big
companies doing the cloud and that
hundred number is pretty disappointing
for me right but so so i'm making think
of it as a one-percent observation of
the reality of large data and our data
set sizes tend to be in this hundred
terabyte range um with a couple of
exceptions notably scientific data sets
just that seems to be a natural size
that you can accumulate on funded
projects to get the bigger data sets are
coming from something like an
accelerator or the LSST which they don't
seem to be able to manufacture except
for lenses
and and so that these these individual
petascale data sets were just not seen
that the biggest simulations if you take
a meaningful set of observations from
them produce hundreds of terabytes um
this will certainly scale but but right
now it's not petabytes of data set um
five years ago we built the Graywolf
system it was named after Jim Gray it
was supposed to be a beowulf like
clustered system for databases hence the
name um it's essentially commodity
storage top of network switches to you
servers for you storage 48 this server
running Microsoft sequel server and at
the time it's a petabyte system um
completed three and a half years ago it
it performs 70 gigabytes a second of Io
through Microsoft sequel server database
so that's the query output that we
benchmark in one the 2008 storage
challenge at supercomputing um I was
disappointed that the that the plaque
they gave me was so blurry I mean it's
unfortunate um so that sort of still our
baseline architecture we went on to
explore new architectures and and this
is our atom I on cluster so this is low
powered motherboards with integrated
GPUs that our memory map some SSD some
hard drives the whole thing cost thirty
thousand dollars and this is two years
ago um 36 nodes 1.2 kilowatts thirty
thousand dollars doing 18 gigabits of
second of gigabytes a second arroyo um
and so this is sort of was our
exploration of of what you can do with
commodity hardware and the idea is
behind this we're driven by gene Amdahl
Gordon Bell and Jim Gray is to is to
tune the processor capabilities down to
get a system with IO balance there's
been another paper in this space is
really quite good you might have heard
of called fawn by dave anderson at CMU
explores this same design space and so
this was a this is not a cluster that
we're going to deploy data sets on but
it was an interesting experiment and fed
into the cluster were currently building
which is the data scope so this is an
NSF yep the skies whatever the name was
was your typical throughput of that
system you know to compare it to where
your system can actually do
ok so the Sloan Digital Sky server has
probably are running 20 of the Graywolf
nodes on that data set so that it's a
multi-tenant system right and most of
them are relatively low throughput high
query education samples casual use we
also have a batch service called cast
jobs that is the high throughput users
and I think we're doing five gigabytes a
second out of it so not a huge fraction
of the the aggregate bandwidth of the
system um and I'd say that that that
characterizes gray wolf a gray wolf like
most MapReduce clusters ends up not
getting the workload to tax all of the
hardware um good question so the the
system that that we're starting to
assemble right now is is a
one-million-dollar nsf-funded datascope
supposed to be a microscope for data
essentially um and it's it's I don't
want to go through all of it it's a
heterogeneous system that combines multi
tiers of performance and storage has
GPUs and SSDs combined and so some some
things that we're going to do it's going
to be 5 petabytes and change and do 460
gigabytes a second of bio and so this is
what data intensive computing looks like
at the edge in academia um and the node
count is is 200 right so pretty pretty
small okay so one of the multi-tenant
data sets is I'm doing great okay
computational turbulence um bit and this
is actually where this talk starts from
I normally give a turbulence talk to
more sciency crowds um so these are
giant fluid simulation
10-24 to the fourth that that I'll put
hundreds of terabytes petabytes um
typically in computational fluid
turbulence you're analyzing dynamics on
the fly on a supercomputer eyes you're
doing the simulation they store a few
snapshots this is tradition but what if
new questions arise like you need the
time evolution of data or you're in the
situation now if you've already run the
simulation and you didn't collect the
statistics you need you can re simulate
or you can keep these massive datasets
to reload either which one of you need
to have a supercomputer and what we want
to do is use data intensive computing to
decouple high resolution fluid dynamics
from supercomputing and we do this by
storing all the data let's ignore that
quote and so we we take on an entire
simulation run hundreds of terabytes so
we're taking one tenth of the snapshots
that are computed in this direct
numerical simulation and that number is
you need to compute at a finer
granularity than you need to track
particles at or do statistics at um just
for for correctness criteria and then
we've so we build this these hundred
terabyte data sets and they're available
for ad hoc inspection for data mining
for feature extraction find me
interesting turbulent structures what's
the pre evolution of this vortex um
public access and it's also
retrospective studies so we're creating
a service that's beginning to get used
in the terminus community like the Sloan
Digital Sky Survey gets used in the
astrophysics community in this database
in some sense stores a computational
effort you do this giant simulation you
store the data that captures that
simulation so that it doesn't need to be
repeated and you can access the output
um it it separates the simulation the
solving of the equations from the
experiments you actually conduct the
experiments on the data output separated
in time separating Speight in a
different computer system in this data
intensive environment um and and it's
been a really powerful tool it's also
allowed
people to do new classes experiment that
aren't possible in simulation space so
you can iterate back and forth in time
you can't run simulations backwards and
so they destabilize and so there's
there's studies about like the pre
evolution like if you see a feature how
did that feature form that people are
executing on this database that are not
possible in a supercomputer so that's
the value proposition of this this
cluster it's a web services cluster um
this is our front page from a couple
months ago and this is the number that
we like which is 52 billion points
queried right so it gets used some not
not ridiculous amounts and it's a
sharted database it's kind of what you'd
expect we take the turbulence space we
decompose it spatially by time step we
shard the spatial decomposition on to
multiple nodes and we use a mediator
again it's all sequel server 2008 in
this case um and you access it from web
services so our for tron Fortran and C
Python are major user community
community as Fortran and I appreciate
that that use the irony of using for
train and web services but it's it's
that easy it's a Fortran call out I have
a code example I think I cut it out um
because you don't need to read Fortran
the I guess that the workloads that this
service presents and this is going to be
the last slide before we dive back into
scheduling which is what I care about is
is how when you design a service like
this and people want to conduct queries
against these simulations you present
them an interface and in in there's
interfaces the interface design process
was interesting and where we ended up
was trying to create an interface that
allowed for batch scheduling because if
you give to low-level and interface if
you for example a lot of people to say
get me the velocity or gradient or the
point or get me this energy at this one
location and they're submitting these
one at a time there's both the huge cost
for web service invocation and there's
little opportunity to do optimization in
reorganization at the service this is
sort of the database argument right if
you give me you query you tell me what
you want I can reorganize it to optimize
it now it to a high level if you say
tell me the evolution of a million
particles 3,000 time steps that doesn't
provide enough inside and in the
experiment so we decided on an interface
which is essentially to give baptism
points the batches of points tend to be
10,000 to a hundred thousand in size on
a time step and then allow the database
engine to compute gradients filters
Colonel computations and this is the
active database principle so we're
trying to capture the the compute at the
data on the databases using user-defined
functions and and then the client code
can do some minor customization so if
you want to track particles you will ask
for smooth interpolated velocities at
all these different points get the
velocities back update your particle
locations then ask for new velocities at
the next time step all right back to
computer science so your your computer
sciences university you spend your
seventy dollars trying to build the data
intensive computing system you do it and
the only thing that can happen is you
can fail or you can succeed and this is
a this was Jim Gray's comment about the
Sloan Digital Sky Survey and I loved it
um and so we built this in people use it
52 billion times but all of a sudden
we're i/o bound eighty percent over x
loading the data we have DB queries that
you can write one line of fortran that
will launch terabytes of data access
scans last hours today's a single query
can consume all the i/o resources and
the more popular your intensive data
intensive services the more collapses we
don't have the ability from an
investment or resource standpoint to do
dynamic replication
new instances and even if we do we're
i/o bound so we need to copy all the i/o
as well copy all the data to get new i/o
resources involved um this might be
amenable to some content style caching
like taking the popular data out and we
do that some right like we take popular
data out and instantiate a separate
service but at the end of the day people
are scanning large data sets we don't
know what they're scanning and we get
big iOS and so this graph just shows
that that we have queries depending on
on what computation you ask for at the
database that lasts for you know ten to
the third seconds pretty commonly for a
reasonable number of points for 10,000
points so okay so so we went to tackle
this problem using this notion of shared
scans and that's where we started we
started with these i/o services that
were choked and we wanted to provide
data driven bad scheduling that
essentially Co schedules queries by the
spatial sub reason that they access so
looking at queries that access the same
region of time space or in astronomy
same region of space coast schedule m we
also wanted to tackle starvation and um
and coordinate the cash in with the
scheduler and so this is where our
approach ends up being different from
what happened in MapReduce and not
produce you sort of instantiate a
MapReduce computation you define all the
mappers you do the computation you tear
it all down right that's not the way
databases work databases you do queries
against a database you have an
essentially the database the buffer pool
carries from query to query and so
there's a lot of benefits of caching um
so for astronomy and astrophysics what's
this looks like is you have a
space-filling curve index so the circles
of spatial index just like a partition
cube they're actually use the exact same
data structure use a quadtree um and so
you'll have SQL queries which are select
from where and we'll use some some
user-defined functions like a
nearest-neighbor function or a filter
function and and these queries will
define sub-query regions you can
partition a query based on the subspaces
it accesses
you can then reorganize these subspaces
and essentially take the the three
queries query 1 2 & 3 to the blue
subspace and execute them in one I oh so
this is where we started just on Io as
well um do the reorder in the coast
scheduling the co scheduling has some
secret sauce that that that does some
time agent wait time age waiting to
prevent starvation um and we do things
by most popular queries first so we
actually get worse batching in the sense
but we are greedy and we are greedy
because of the cash oh and so with the
cash it actually turns out to be
beneficial to be greedy we ran this
experiment because we publish our paper
they publish their paper people said you
got it backwards and we ran it in it
it's we only got it backwards if you
don't cash cashing turns it upside down
which I thought was interesting um some
observations is so these are the top ten
spatial regions based on the database um
there's a fundamental partition size
that underlies the database and so I
think each one of these is eight meg and
so that but the top regions get lots and
lots of repeated reuse and all this is
in the cache and in it goes to there are
interesting things in the sky there's a
whole bunch of data that's interesting a
whole bunch of data that's not
interesting I don't think that's very
profound to say that there are
interesting things in the sky and so
here's the the big picture is if you
don't do any sharing you get can't be
point one queries per second
but when you are varying the the
starvation resistance bias you can
double your throughput and so I think
that that doubling our throughput is
better than fifty percent improved
throughput but that also reflects that
we have a lot more locality and cash
locality to exploit than they did in
MapReduce okay now as we went to
turbulence we started to look at going
from these query sharing two jobs
sharing and as as a way to get towards
workflows right because queries are not
people don't do individual query if they
don't do individual MapReduce jobs they
do MapReduce jobs and workflows they do
queries in sequences of queries and jobs
in turbulence this has a very simple
form which is you're doing um iterative
queries to time steps sometimes derided
sometimes backwards sometimes forward
but there are these access patterns and
so the idea is if we had queries that
accessed regions r1 r3 and r4 here in
life raft that there's this opportunity
for sharing among r3 and r4 that life
raft phone access because it doesn't see
the are it's trying to schedule query
are one in query are two and so if you
then add some job awareness to look at
actually do some loop unrolling and ask
what are all the things that are going
to be accessed you can you can merge the
streams and improve the performance
pretty simple idea um it has a solving
this problem has a database query
optimizer feel it you do in dynamic
programming algorithms of high
polynomial complexity I think this
there's an N squared phase in an N cubed
phase but but that's how databases work
and it works ok because there's not so
many queries um so we greedily assemble
the amount of pairwise jobs sharing is a
dynamic program and then we we look at
assemblies of these pairwise it's a very
confusing picture but I guess the the
one thing is that that each one of these
horizontal lines is a sequence that
corresponds to a job these blue lines
represent dependencies which are called
gating edges and representations so the
that after this finishes our two it's
going to do this single region three job
on one partition the database that is a
low throughput job but it enables all
three queries to go to r4 at the same
time right just like the intuition and
so these this the the process of doing
the optimization to schedule this is to
take the jobs to build these gating
edges and then to assemble the gating
edges in a global schedule it's not very
efficient small instances the the query
optimization efficiency is not a big
deal these type of slow relatively slow
high polynomial collect complexity Corey
optimizers are used in joint processing
all the time and this is now better this
is a three times improvement so no
sharing versus job awareness we compared
a couple variants of life raft in
between and and decompose it to see
where the benefits come from so twenty
two percent of the better benefit is
from query reordering so just as regular
life raft being able to do things um
based on the amount of sharing um twelve
percent from something I didn't talk
about but but thirty percent more comes
from this joint awareness alright so
this so excuse me job awareness so this
understanding these job sequences and
being able to look at the iterative
loops and schedule based on those is
very valuable in achieving this
throughput improvement okay yeah then
maybe a business so I understand your
point about trying to
building jobs that are seeing across
different tests together that makes
sense how do you how does it program
specify what each one of these jobs is
in that see what's a check you know are
five or four ah so there's there are
declarative interfaces which you can use
as hints and we will we will do it like
prefetching to where we will look at
striated access patterns and try and
figure out what a loop is going to do so
if you have a program right so you write
a Python program that says for I want to
iterate over this these time steps
here's a thousand points call but a
batch of get velocity if that should get
velocity gradient so we're going to see
the first one we're going to see the
second one and we're going to assume
straight at access and it just works
because the patterns are so simple um so
so you can either if you want a program
to it declare it the mediator in the in
this mediator architecture is is is
doing query rewriting already right
because it's getting is getting a query
that's to the global database rewriting
it for the sharded database that
mediator can also look at what time step
it was on what time step the previous
one was on and it's it's a it's a simple
process that works yep
for this I the response time figure for
joints the the response time is is sort
of a weird one because it response time
ends up always going down because you're
increasing throughput and I think that
that that's the way it gets reported and
that's not it's sort of not good enough
right because there's also response time
variants which is in a way more
important like any time you take a
service and you increase the throughput
your average response talk is going to
go down no this is little thought yeah
um your average response time is going
to go down right so we're concerned not
only the average response time but the
response time variant so how predictable
is the service and the response time
maximum in this data intensive world
people tend to punt which is to say data
intensive bachelor and computing these
jobs already run for a long time we're
not going to worry about it we need
starvation to be bounded and reasonable
so the this
was this figure so this figure is um
looks at this is this 120 is essentially
a how starvation resistant we are and I
didn't talk about this but so so this is
the throughput if you're very sensitive
to starvation so this is actually
reduced response time compared to know
sheriff I for ordering and then this
figure is if you're not starvation
resistant and the response time here is
more than that the maximum response time
is here more than double to give you an
intuition and so there there is this
knob that says if you're if you're
starvation sensitive you can still get
some benefits right because you're still
sharing even if you're scheduling things
to try and enforce good completion
orders um but there's if you're
completely relaxed about starvation you
get more and more throughput I don't
have a great answer as to where you want
to be how you want to tune this
parameter in the other thing about this
parameters vary workload sensitive so
when you present a little bit of load to
the server you want this parameter tuned
all the way to maximize sharing when you
get a lot of workload to the server
other way around but the point is is is
there's no this this parameter need to
be tuned dynamically so it's very
difficult
alright how am i doing okay so this is
not this is a this is appearing this
year in 2000 in supercomputing and is
related to the notion of bad scheduling
it's it's not really on topic but it's
inspired by the same set of ideas and
the results are great so I wanted to
throw it in there um but a lot of these
computations in spatial databases are
doing colonel computations smoothing
gradients Lagrangian Terp elation is the
most important one and so this means
that you you pick a random point a
target point in this case X prime Y
Prime there's a set of grid points
around it that need to that define the
colonel that's going to participate in
answering that query um and and again
our our queries consist of batches of
points so maybe 10,000 points per time
step that are being delivered right and
and so what this means is that we end up
with a series of kernels in green here
on different fragments of our data the
blue and and then sub-queries associated
with each one so these aren't represent
that there's the p1 has a sub query on
region 0 now they're shared regions and
the idea is is again a pretty
straightforward one which is to take the
data to iterate over it in a linear
space filling curve order so even though
you're not inherently a streaming
workload to treat it like a data stream
and to execute from 0 1 2 3 4 5 you can
see this is a this is a what's called a
Z order 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 right it's a
as opposed to row major column major in
in by the the way that you can
accomplish this is if you have
decomposable functions so if your kernel
function can be decomposed into partial
sums and computed in parts you can
essentially exchange memory which is
having all these partial sums that
you're
accumulating for i/o coherency insuk
went and sequentiality and so that's the
idea um we do all our i/o now in this
database service in a streaming pass and
um and this is was a really wow result
for me because I thought this is going
to be a nice little thing but it's it's
a factor of ten more efficient then the
naive implementation which is to do each
query and so there's two things that are
happening one is that you never you
access each data element once so you
never access something in in a colonel
and then come back and access it later
when your space filling curve circles
around but more importantly all of your
i/o are aligned their sequential their
concurrent so they fully exercise all
the parallelism of the hardware at every
level of the revolution no these blocks
together and reuse the country now so
that most of the functions that you want
to do differentiation integration are
can be represented by partial sums right
so like the the computational
integration method is is in and so it it
applies to everything we want to do um
you know different linear combinations
of regions all right the regions might
overlap but I might not have earth
unless I could find some no Krylov
subspace Azure I don't know
something some things that I could reuse
amongst those you know am i right with
the property you actually need is you
need to be able to to look at so so you
have a colonel you need to be able to
look at the data element of the colonel
independent of all the other data
elements in that Colonel it's not that
the jobs interact it's it's that um that
as long as you can you don't need to
have a global view of what your
computing so there are there are plenty
of examples of things that don't work in
this model um for filtering integration
differentiation interpolation it's in
general is that I mean you can produce
big data down to smaller data and you
can use less of the cash if you'll give
this whole region is saying I'm going to
compute something in summarize that
rather than rather than have to keep way
too good data so here's what happens is
you is you is for this kernel right
you're going to start you're going to
start the solution at zero you're going
to create some memory to allocate it and
take and add the partials form 0 at the
partial sum from 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and then
you have to wait and keep that in memory
so for every partial sum you're spending
memory we actually measure the memory
bandwidth as part of this to ask a
question like we are having you're not
completing things you're accumulating
them and is that important and the
answer's no that that for it's it's
hundreds of megabytes of partial results
so in the worst case
um and so this notion is it's pretty
powerful in it it reflects what people
have learned in GPU program for example
right which is you need to do coherent
access to data throughout the entire
cache hierarchy um one way to go ahead
pushing by the system so you have a
comedian layer which interprets
and this optimization is done on the
individual node so individual is all
sequel server yeah so that how do you
tactimon to see for sure
who are the factory we all other things
before some of these to secrecy okay so
that the mediator so we have a series of
sequels servers we have a the mediator
is not a sequel server it's taking
queries doing query rewriting based on
this facial and sending these sub
queries to the individual sequel servers
so when we want to do something like
merge queries we're taking two queries
that our cue to the mediator rewriting
them as a merge query against the shard
the database chart so then this
optimization is actually has to be done
at the database because it's actually
about the the way you iterate over the
data so we've rewritten the query
execution engine both in this mediator
level which is abstract it's it's it's
rewriting SQL but at a pretty simple
level like if you have a user-defined
function or predicate we don't write we
don't even look inside it right we're
just we're taking tables and Deacon
dividing by space and then this query
execution strategy is inside a
user-defined function so the
user-defined function is interpolate
around this spot and the implementation
the user-defined function used to be
grab the data in the kernel perform the
interpolation return the point and now
the implementation of that user-defined
function is generate the partial sum and
populate it as you do a data stream so
yeah if ms is different virus
dated so everything i'm showing you
right now is read-only queries yeah
oh the that issue is going to come up a
lot as we move on to graph oriented data
but the we try very very hard to make
things read-only and if we do read right
to have a really big database and then
write to a separate area yeah um not a
group not the most satisfying answer but
that's what we do um so one of the ways
to visualize how you get this ten times
improvement is by looking at the
effectiveness of read ahead in the
number of physical reads so with this
streaming I Oh Colonel computations the
number of physical reads is this blue
line and compared to the red line so
this is a thousand fewer physical reads
and what's happening is that because
we've created the sequential pass over
the data everything is this is the
effectiveness of of read ahead right so
we're essentially getting all the i/o
done and read ahead by the substance
we've created as iostream that the
system understands and works well with
prefetching hardware and prefetching
policies in the operating system all the
data gets delivered and by the time we
consume it its it's there right and so
when you compare it if you do this
direct evaluations what d stands for
read ahead is essentially totally
ineffective so so the outcome is just
take these queries rewrite them globally
so they conform to the policies the
operating system expects and the
database expects and it applies so that
was fun um and and this is sort of the
end of the data intensive computing
portion of it which is that that this
i/o sharing and data streaming is really
important for high-throughput science
right it's the difference between having
these services that don't work at all
use by 10 users and these services that
don't work at all used by 100 users
I mean it's just a different pain point
in our experience is that that pretty
much as many people use it as can slow
it down and but what we need we're all
about supporting concurrent users and
public accessibility and those are the
people that the service is most valuable
to our people that want to do
computational fluids that don't work at
Los Alamos so we have a guy at the at
the West Point that this service is
transformed his life he went there used
to be in graduate school had super
computer has no super computer time and
has been able to just transferred his
resources research this and do it for
free um people that work with big data
systems and in the cloud and industry
already know this but it's it's a lot
more difficult to scale i/o than it is
to scale out either computer capacity
it's just not this the shareable
resource and it gets very congested
these type of dating show techniques are
valuable okay so last thing this is our
laser so we sent dan dan wang my student
who's going to salesforce graduating
this year to yahoo last summer to try
and get this all together um and and so
we went back to the cloud and we're
going to try and take some of these
database techniques starvation
resistance caching and apply them to pig
hadoop nova is their workflow engine in
yahoo home and in tackle the big problem
which is to eliminate redundant
processing to go from just scans and
actually do the entire programs so that
we can get these memory benefits as well
um we want to share reducers so we
transfer the day over the network one so
we wanted here too soft deadlines and so
be able to control this latency
throughput gain goes to the question
that was asked to earlier okay so what
this looks like is you get workflows we
run it through a workflow merger in this
case um that that that we have a job
here C 2 s 0
that can be merged um and we merge the
workflows now this merge workflow it's
only one element that actually is an
entire MapReduce program right or a pig
program and so that means that that
merge workflows shares the splitter
shares a combiner shares a shuffle you
in we take MapReduce programs and we
rewrite them to align the partitioning
functions and run them as one program
and you also show the workflow costs
which are substantial the start up and
tear downs cost for the for the the
MapReduce environment the it's funny
because workflows are a great concept
and we got this figure we show we merge
one part of our 10 step workflow the
benefits are actually come from we
started earlier saying that many many
MapReduce programs are sort of simple
maps that with nothing reducers and and
that applies here as well that the data
on these front end stages are so much
bigger than the data as it go through
aggregates there Nova I don't know
nobody has been similar lately it's me
it's it's a workflow engine on top of
kicking on top of MapReduce right so
he's my more basic question is that
it's easier to do this merging because
you have a structured typed language
like C will rightly or something like
Pig writing there it allows you to merge
this together versus say I use it if I'm
constantly right and plug in to
MapReduce which makes it quite a lot
hard-hearted emerge
so okay so so each each dot here is a
pig or MapReduce function Nova is the
system that allows you to connect up
these MapReduce functions and and run
them right the pig is not sequel enough
to do the type of optimization you're
talking about so what we end up doing is
taking map programs that apply to the
same data realigning their partition
errs and there are restrictions on how
you can change the way the map input
work and then essentially running two
programs decide rewriting a map that is
map one map to right so we're not doing
any fine grain program rewriting or just
laying them out though yeah and there's
in their safety restrictions you could
get a lot more if you could look inside
and do corey optimization like you might
be doing to joins that could be shared
we can only see the joins in the we can
see some joints but but you can do stuff
inside the program that we won't touch
right and so the this ends up and this
actually goes to the question use ask
which is that all the IO gets shared
when you have shared joint so this is
three jobs against these ABC inputs and
and the takeaway here is if you execute
them separately they have an IO cost and
a computation cost and that if you
execute them together you can share the
ico cost but the computation cost will
be somehow reduced right not all the
computations it's not redundant um in
and so we see some benefit there as well
and in the takeaway is is for the pig
mix workload which is yahoo's internal
cloud they call it grid benchmark um it
this ends up being sort of better in
every dimension so this is no sharing
and these are all the different variants
that got tested with but the takeaway is
is you're using fewer resources and
meeting more deadlines for all the
variants fewer resources because sharing
and more deadlines not because it's more
fair but because the higher throughput
reduces average latency and gives you
enough wiggle room to meet more
deadlines it's less fair right and in
this notion is important about computing
that that fairness in the number of
deadlines you mean and fairness and
response time are only loosely coupled
because they're such throughput
differences that come from sharing
Yahoo's internal the benchmark
how many jobs
so this was on a 16 node cluster it's
pretty cool how many jobs fast no jobs
that they have 17 different types of
jobs and there is an intensity knob that
allows you to specify the the inbound
workload right um so if you want to dig
into this I'm going to actually fail so
there's a there's door right there oh um
and similarly more throughput lower
response time and sort of this is where
we are in computer science everything
old is new many of these techniques have
pleasant similarities to tape scheduling
there's a whole bunch of work on I'm
going to do a tape scan how do I morge
multiple programs through these tapes
cans together that is similar this space
is more complex because there's cashing
in the memory hierarchy and you get more
flexibility you rewrite but if this is
not a new idea space um shared scans are
better in every way there's no downside
to them and that that this streaming
technique has has huge benefits and and
I think we're just starting to look at
how generally applicable this is and so
a question for me moving forward is is
should I take so it seems like streaming
computing has been done because they're
inherently datos troops in limited
memory resources and what this says to
me is that there's value in doing
streaming computing on any computation
as long as you can represent it as a
stream um this is consistent with so
Stanford has had this stream
supercomputer project for a handful of
years that that explores the same idea
some of the parallel computing in
systolic arrays builds off similar
principles um but the the notion of
doing reordering of jobs to get friendly
date access patterns is powerful and
needs to be explored much more in my
opinion alright